arbeitswelten haben sich rasant
verändert die industrialisierung brachte
uns einst die massenproduktion mit der
computerisierung entstanden neue berufe
und heute zu beginn der digitalen
revolution fragen wir uns wie sieht die
arbeit von morgen aus
wie gehen wir mit dieser rasanten
entwicklung um die frage beschäftigt
arbeitspsychologe theo wehner seit
langem anzahl von arbeiterinnen und
arbeitern gemacht haben
das machen wir heute mit der hälfte
dieser produktionsarbeit berufsbilder
arbeitswelten sind im wandel in der
ausstellung der historiker exhibition
werfen zeitgenössische künstler einen
blick darauf
die technische entwicklung vermischt was
früher strikt getrennt war
beruf und privatleben der künstler great
little nahm das vorweg man kann kunst
nicht fehlinterpretiert
wenn man das hier tut dann sieht man
dass vieles deskriptive ist rein
beschreibend bilder porträts abwesenheit
von gefühlen ehrgeiz und siegeswille
auch das ist ihr thema doch nicht jeder
kann in der realen arbeitswelt auf dem
siegertreppchen stehen
das führt zu dauerfrust dadurch dass sie
nur noch leistung braucht ist sie auch
eine tiefe kränkung
es wird nicht mehr meine anstrengung
wirklich verlangt es werden kompetenzen
spezialisiert und die werden abgerufen
und wenn die nicht zum sieg führen dann
bin ich zweiter dritter eigentlich
letzte austauschbar
im laufe des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
wurde bezahlte arbeit zunehmend
sinnstiftend wir identifizieren uns
durch unsere berufe karriere musste sein
koste es was es wolle eine
leistungsgesellschaft und eigentlich das
sehen wir in dem kunstwerk hinter uns es
ist eine erfolgsgeschichte
es kommt auch die trophäen an die man
mit nach hause bringt sogar stress ist
zum leistungsausweis geworden im job
sind viele einzelkämpfer
gemeinschaftliches denken und handeln
oft fehlanzeige
selbst in teamsitzungen die sich schon
so nennen
profiliert sich wird erwartet dass sich
jeder einzelne profiliert der
konkurrenzkampf könnte zunehmen das foto
von andreas gursky zeigt was heute
normal ist roboter die für uns arbeiten
die frage ist für oder gegen uns
was macht es dann mit uns braucht uns
dann nur noch als konsumenten oder
werden neue tätigkeiten entstehen und
die gesellschaft müssen sich darauf
richten was bedeutet es wenn wir von
arbeiten befreit werden die wirklich von
einem roboter erledigt werden
die ausstellung als rückschau konzipiert
kann darauf keine antwort geben
doch sie bietet anstoß zum lustvollen
nachdenken